but within families there's always ego
intention always there's the brother the
sister the mother the cousin whatever if
you are unable to fire your own mother
you shouldn't run the family business
because you've got to think about the
business first
of course i've like many people um been
mesmerized many times by the endless
endless cycle of shark tank and airs uh
24 7 365 whether you're walking through
an airport a lobby at home
it just it never stops it's incredible
this incredible show that is now in your
what is it 13th season or something like
that yeah we're in the middle of the
13th season right now
it's really an incredible success that
um i know people just can't get enough
of i i likened it to a little bit of
when it first started when american idol
first started you would watch people
being like i want to be a singer and
then
you'd watch them sing and you're like
either they are terrible and you get
some joy out of that or you're like oh
my god this person is incredible and
there's something about watching people
pitch successful business ideas to or
pitch ideas to successful business
people and hearing what kind of feedback
you give them that i don't know why but
obviously a lot of people feel that way
it's exciting it's exciting to either
see them go down in flames or get you
guys to compete and start wanting to
invest in that business
well it's really hard to get financial
freedom singing if you get a hit product
and you sell hundreds of millions of
dollars of it which happens all the time
on shark tank these days just because
you think it's a hot product doesn't
mean it's so you need a portfolio
approach because my biggest winners were
ones i thought weren't going to work and
vice versa is that really true you're
big like your biggest winners you
weren't even convinced that were going
to be that successful yeah i took a
flyer because i like the person or the
team or the woman or the man pitching it
and the end the thing ends up making me
millions of dollars you just don't know
and that's why you can't stop watching
it it really is
it it's kind of it you know it's a
combination of of lock timing marketing
skills social media all of these things
have to come together uh to make a
product really work or a business and
and we've learned that i mean that's why
you know every day in my portfolio of
over 34 companies now there's something
euphoric going on on a few of them and
catastrophic on the other it's like a
passion play the phone is ringing i'm
getting emails oh we're going out of
business the other ones just said we're
being acquired for 10 times revenue you
just don't know and that's what i love
about it yeah i i imagine that's a
pretty exciting thing well how do you
handle
the catastrophic news like when you get
news that like look this business is in
the [ __ ] and you know you put your
money into it like
i guess i feel like most people would be
like don't get too emotional but isn't
it almost impossible to stay without
emotion when you get those kinds of
calls well i want to assure you when i
lose money i cry like a baby i really do
because it's so hard to make it and it
doesn't matter how much you have when
you kill it that way it's just really
stressful but the way i look at it is
look it's going to happen some
percentage even in venture capital you
know if you can look back since the
1950s you're only going to get a two out
of 10 that are really going to work and
they're going to pay for the other eight
dogs you invested in but on shark tank
we do way better because we have
hundreds of millions of people watching
the show and so at the end of the day
after through syndication and
international distribution
products get distributed worldwide as
people get to know them it's the most
powerful eight minutes of consumer
advertising you can get that's why
everybody wants to bring their idea to
shark tank you know which one i remember
by the way sometimes you know these
things i don't know if you'll remember
this one you probably will because you
invested in it but it was seized it was
multiple it was many seasons ago but i
remember watching this pitch and and
watching you uh you know compete for it
it was a guy who had come up with a
play-doh
that was maybe it was like for
like some type of out like had an
ingredient missing that no one had had
um
had thought to do you know what i'm
talking about yeah i do and i do
and then you you um he wanted to give
you
he had agreed to give you 49 and you
were like nah 51 cause i need to be able
to
you know
make decisions on this thing and he
ended up going for it and i thought it
was a brilliant idea a concept i don't
know whatever happened with the company
you know
products like that aren't companies yet
they're just products and that's why i
need 51 because i know at the end of the
day a lot of people have great ideas
but you need executional skills with
great ideas you can't just have a great
idea they're a dime a dozen executional
skills are really hard to find so when
you combine executional skills with a
great idea then you have a business but
that doesn't happen that often so when i
see somebody there's a great product no
distribution no idea what to do with it
maybe i'll take a flyer but i'm not
going to let them manage it i mean look
you got to take you have to tell the
truth on these situations i'm the only
shark that tells the truth everybody
else lies to everybody trying to make
them feel better yeah hey man i'm on
your side a thousand percent now
uh the new show
money court you're going to be flanked
by a trial attorney and
a former uh public a former public
defender and judge and you're taking
real people's money issues and and
hearing them out and making a decision
giving them advice and having the the
other two attorneys weigh in on it what
do you find is
the most common
money issue for most people because
money is obviously such a huge
factor in all of our lives we live in
this
capitalistic world in society so money
is a thing that people argue about
people you know break up over people get
together over it's a huge thing
so what what is like the most common
issue you find when it comes to money
so the the problem if you think about
categorically uh small business in
america represents 65 percent of job
creation mostly these are family
businesses that were started sometimes
by the existing generation or maybe the
previous generation and they've grown to
30 40 50 60 100 million dollars in sales
and they're successful but within
families there's always ego intention
always there's the brother the sister
the mother the cousin whatever and you
know even though the business is
really successful these emotional
aspects surface every once in a while
and cause a lot of chaos
and it's sort of the way i tell
everybody this
is to think about this if you're if you
are unable to fire your own mother you
shouldn't run the family business
because you've got to think about the
business first
it is what sustains everybody all the
employees all the customers all the bank
loans all the investors you got to take
care of the business you can't let
yourself get caught up in a huge legal
battle with your brother what a dumb
idea but it happens all the time and
that was the essence of what money court
is and so what we tried to do is first
of all break the log jam that's been
created during the pandemic there are
tens of thousands of cases waiting to
get into court because the courts
haven't really been open during the
pandemic so they've decided to go to
arbitration now you can choose who
arbitrates your case
and what's really interesting about this
we started casting it because these are
real cases the real litigation real
money here they've got to sign a
contract that they abide by my rendering
by my decision and many of the people
said you know i don't really like that
mr wonderful but i trust him
how about that and that just shows you
telling the truth is not a bad thing
because at least you they think they'll
you'll render the truth i've got katie
fang with me who's absolutely
spectacular she's a trial attorney i've
got anna pozzo and she's amazing too
adam knows exactly
what it's like to sit on a bench because
that's what she did she can smell bs a
mile away and when it comes to contract
law
you know katie fans like a weasel she'll
rip your flesh if she smells anything
wrong with what you're telling her and i
love it i've got these fantastic legal
advisors but ultimately i render the
decision so you make the final decision
i i saw a clip i think it's from the new
show or or maybe it was from an
interview that you did promoting it or
something where you said
that you it was your take on when family
asks for money in this clip you said you
know when family asks for money i have
like a basically a steadfast rule that i
stick to which is
if i'm giving you the money i'll give
you the money and it's not a loan you
don't have to give it back
but you'll you you never ask me for
money again
it's worked for me
i constantly get asked for money and
with my own family this happens anytime
one family member has a windfall it's my
advice to them everybody's going to come
crawling out of the woodwork saying look
i want to open a bowling alley a
restaurant a disco i want to buy a truck
whatever it is
and if you get yourself into a situation
where you have family members owing you
money which you know with certainty
they're never going to pay you back
you're way better to say look i'll lend
you this no not as a loan it's a gift
it's yours i was very fortunate i'm
gifting this money
never call me for money again that's our
unwritten contract and i've lived
through that many times and i'm able to
go to thanksgiving dinner every year and
smile at everybody and they smile at me
we have no tension we have an
understanding and do does has anyone who
ever
borrow or taken that money and been like
all right thanks have they ever tried to
hit you up again
of course but we have an agreement
you're having agreement with the deal
yeah look you know i i everybody
everybody's life is full of
complications and that's just the nature
of family there's always the black sheep
there's always the story there's always
the mother-in-law i mean that's what
makes life interesting and there's never
a day that isn't boring but you know
i've got a lot of ceos that i invest in
i've got a lot of operating companies i
have my own operating company you know i
try and keep a balance in life but at
the same time i realize how it works
you've got to be transparent you've got
to be honest and sometimes people can't
stand the truth well kevin let me ask
you something i i do pretty well and i
make a good living and uh my mom keeps
hitting me up for [ __ ] man like it's
constant it's luggage it's trips to
casinos i just bought her a freaking
macbook so she can just play bridge like
it never ends do i just keep buying her
stuff because she's gonna die someday
yeah if it's your mother you gotta keep
buying her stuff okay so that's the
that's the one i mean that's the one
that's the one rule you can't mess with
your mother it's bad karma man but
everybody else i can tell them to yeah
they're not your mother hit the bricks
yeah okay cool just wanted to make sure
on that she's gonna love this portion of
the show so um now i wanted i i read a
thing about your your investment
philosophy about age versus whole you
know holding stocks and bonds i wanted
to know
do you have an opinion on on real estate
do you believe that
having real estate as an investor is a
good idea worthwhile or lexi this is my
this is my take on this before you tell
me i feel like people are drawn to
the types of investing they're familiar
with so i have friends who their
families uh they were raised in real
estate families in other words the
family owns homes and apartments
encounters that they run out so as the
kids get older that's what they invest
in my father was a stock broker so it
was like
the market is what i'm familiar with and
i feel comfortable with but i've also
thought of diversifying in the way of
getting like into an investment property
i'm wondering if you think that is wise
or not
yeah i do have a lot of real estate in
my portfolio but i'll tell you a rule
that my mother taught me who was not a
you know analyst or a portfolio manager
but she did incredibly well during her
life
simple rules she said never put more
than five percent into one any one
position and never more than 20 into any
one sector including real estate and her
theory was that no matter what happens
if something blows up on you and it's
only a five percent position it can't
wipe you out where people get killed
particularly in real estate particularly
in commercial real estate which has gone
under a lot of pressure because people's
work patterns are changing as a result
of this last year and a half a pandemic
this is not a great asset anymore
because basically some percentage of the
work population never wants to go back
to headquarters and a result you're
seeing all kinds of buildings that used
to be
aaa supreme in boston new york detroit
you know florida miami you name it these
buildings are you know 15 20 empty right
now and everybody's saying don't worry
it'll get back to normal no it isn't
going to go back to normal some
percentage of the population
particularly people work in accounting
logistics
and you know compliance those are the
ones that sit in those cubicles they
have no interest in going back and if
you can't provide them you know
a way to work from their homes in the
suburbs or they're taking care of their
kids and elderly parents they'll just
work for somebody else and so i think at
the end of the day we're going through a
change so i'm not i'm not really as
excited about real estate commercial
real estate as i used to be i still own
a lot of residential i'm okay with that
but not commercial i'm on a breather on
that imagine if you owned a movie
theater chain how screwed you'd be now
oh my god i know i mean like i i think
about the um you know that lawsuit that
was all in the news uh recently uh
scarlett johansson
against uh disney plus for her movie
that came out and you know as somebody
who
i'm a comedian and performer i
automatically side with with scarlet but
then also when i heard the details
at one line of theirs told me how full
of [ __ ]
uh they were which is that you know she
had a theatrical window that her movie
could come out in and that was in the
contract and then they put out a
statement that said she didn't take into
account the um you know all the
pressures and and the catastrophic
effect of covet 19. it's like yeah that
doesn't get you out of the contract
though man but i mean i understand why
their position is we needed to stream it
as well but i still feel like
it's not a legit uh case on their part
yeah i mean look i look at those numbers
almost every week because we have
businesses that support uh movie
theaters and they are down 60 percent
year over year the box offices are
abysmal it's a bloodbath on every
release people
don't want to go back to those places
not just because covid because they're
they're used to streaming they spent a
year and a half streaming anything they
want if you don't want to release your
movie the way people want to watch it
too bad lose money that's exactly what's
happening these people i think they made
james bond five years ago and they're
still waiting to release it i think i'm
not going to a theater to see that if
you can't serve it up to me in my
basement with my own popcorn and my own
can and pop forget it i don't care i'll
watch something else that's the new
reality and you've got to listen to what
the customer wants look if she wants to
get into litigation with disney good
luck
they're not easy to fight with that's
true i mean i don't know how that'll end
up but
point being well let me make a
prediction not well for her
okay and is that prediction just based
on the
the giant that disney is and the and the
the heavy hitters they'll bring you know
i've been working for disney for
almost 15 years and sony and i learned
to respect the way they run their
business and and the way they license
their content and the way they work with
their talent
it's a it's a mutual respect that's
required
i would never litigate the hand that
feeds me i would go sit down and try and
work it out in private quarters they
would respect me for that i remember
when i was negotiating my contract
for shark tank in season three and i
didn't want to have an agent and i went
to see the then president
of abc
the studio that was putting it on the
air owned by disney he said kevin can we
have a frank conversation can we be
honest and transparent with each other
and i said yeah
i negotiate my own deals i don't want to
pay an agent 10 percent he said
yeah you do
and you're going to
because if it's you and me negotiating
your deal there's going to be blood on
this carpet it'll be yours and i don't
want that to happen because i have to
work with you for the years ahead
i would rather draw blood from your
agent who has to work with me every day
for the rest of his life across a wide
range of products and who knows you may
benefit from the fact that he'll horse
trade you you're just meat you're just
talent it's time you learned that here
in hollywood
and i went whoa you got to be kidding
i'm just meat he said yeah
now you're expensive meat
and i met my new agent that afternoon at
the sls hotel his name was jay cerus
we've been together a lot of years 10
years
he made me a ton more money a ton
and the reason was he was able to horse
trade assets across all the studios
that's how hollywood works and it's
never going to change
but you never sue the studio
hey scarlett might want to rethink this
one
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
well i for the record i didn't sue you
disney
if you like that video waiting you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe